The Merc with the mouth is heading back
to the Silver Screen and Wolverine is
coming along for the ride but that might
not be the only surprise hiding in Ryan
Reynolds reveal film star Ryan Reynolds
got the internet rumbling Tuesday with
his Sly announcement that Hugh Jackman
would return to the X-Men Universe
opposite Reynolds Deadpool also known as
The Merc with the mouth in Deadpool 3
come 2024 but in the lead up to the big
reveal online one thing is catching
every comic book Fan's eyes in the
teaser for the Deadpool 3 cool there may
also be a major hint at the return of
X-Force Reynolds and Jackman of course
have had a playful rivalry with each
other and their X-Men characters for
years their comedic relationship began
with Reynold's first appearance as Wade
Wilson who would eventually become
Deadpool in the X-Men spin-off movie
X-Men Origins Wolverine in 2009 but
since the film and the slim origin story
of Deadpool weren't very well received
by critics or fans Reynolds among them
the actor worked diligently to to write
the ship ultimately his efforts got a
proper version of Deadpool made in 2016
with Tim Miller in the director's chair
the film was a massive Blockbuster with
nearly 783 million dollars in worldwide
ticket sales it's David Leach directed
sequel Deadpool 2 eclipsed the original
stake with nearly 786 million dollars
globally two years later Reynolds has
definitely amped up the hype for the
long-awaited Deadpool 3 with the Jackman
announcement it's a major coup for the
producer actor considering his friend
and X-Men Ally announced that he would
no longer play Wolverine after the
character's death in Logan and while it
remains to be seen how Reynolds and
Jackman will bring Wolverine into the
MCU another mystery has already been
teased with a small detail in Reynolds
Deadpool 3 announcement video Ryan
Reynolds expertly executed the
announcement of Hugh Jackman returning
to the X-Men Universe by giving a
soul-searching soliloquy which ended
with him asking Jackman whether he
wanted to play Wolverine one more time
Jackman's response fonts was absolutely
perfect yeah sure during the course of
the video Reynolds is shown in various
outfits including casual clothing and
dead times sitting in front of a
typewriter hilariously typing with one
finger wearing a gray jumpsuit Reynolds
is also seen in the gray suit sitting on
a toilet the sight of the suit prompted
the internet to explode with speculation
Deadpool of course wore his maroon
colored suit in the first two Deadpool
films and it's his go-to outfit in the
comics as well however in his stints as
a member of the X-Force team in Uncanny
X-Force he donned a gray costume with
red X highlights it's a different take
on his classic outfit and definitely
makes a unique statement whether
Reynolds gray jumpsuit and the Wolverine
announcement video turns out to be the
return of X-Force is yet to be seen But
since a modified version of the group
including Domino was introduced in
Deadpool 2 the idea of a reimagined
X-Force appearing in Deadpool 3 is
certainly possible from now on we'll be
known as
X-Force interestingly this isn't the
first mention of Deadpool's gray suit
making a live-action appearance before
the release of the second film rumors
began circulating with the debut of one
of the trailers of Deadpool 2. in that
short announcement it appeared that
Deadpool was done in Gray attire the
idea that the gray look could
potentially be a reveal of X-Force was
quickly debunked though when it was
revealed that the Merc suit was entirely
coated with Ash could Reynold's choice
of suit color be him making good on
Deadpool 2's trailer fake out we'll just
have to see when Deadpool 3 arrives at
theaters on September 6 2024.
foreign
[Music]